good morning everybody we're going to
we have uh two bills that we're going to
be hopefully executing today and uh
let's start out uh representative Cahill
thank you representative
um Mr Clark would you call the roll
please and also while you do that
introduce ours uh substitutions today
okay uh Vice chairman power present
and then we have representative sellers
in for Representatives Guthrie president
click votes present representative Salas
here representative Keller
present Kelly
representative Norwood
president representative Brown here
representative Cahill here represents
Davis here representative
thank you representative representative
Gilman here reference majority here
and we have representative run in for
representative mangaputi here
representative Gallagher
uh here representative Hicks here
representative Holland
um
representative wheelers
I am here
my apologies representative wheeler
uh representative priest here and the
okay uh all 20 are here so we will go
ahead and start and open up the
executive session on Senate bill
47 I believe representative priest has a
motion yes thank you Mr chairman I would
like to make a motion to
approve amendment to 47
okay um I hear you would like to
introduce that amendment is there a
second
Mr chairman I'd be happy to second that
I'm going to have representative stavis
thank you though
uh representative priest would you like
to speak to your Amendment yes sir thank
you
um my amendment is simply adding
23 and 24
the New Hampshire Association of
regional planning commissions
um and this also contains uh this
amendment also contains the changes that
were made from the previous uh meeting
so it includes the conservation uh
uh Direction and it also redirects uh
what the makeup of the committee
basically and other changes
thank you representative representative
Hicks could you clarify for us the
change that might have come from a
potential other amendment that is
contained in here thank you Mr chairman
I'll do my best in the last executive
session we had agreed I think
to return the line about the
representation from the conservation
Community to this and then subsequently
representative priests
wanted to add back in the planning
commission's line as well so that's why
he made that Amendment thank you
representative are there any is there
any discussion on the bill or on the
amendment
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
by Sherman power
yes represent sellers yes click votes
yes representative lasalles yes
representative Keller
yes representative Kelly yes
representative Allwood yes
representative Cahill
no
represents Davis yes
representative Tatro yes representative
yes representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative wrong yes representative
Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative wheeler yay
representative priest yes
and the chairman yes
motion passes 18-2
thank you Mr clerk representative priest
do you have a further motion yes I would
like to oh uh
ought to pass with the amendment HB 47.
I believe you mean Senate Bill 47 I mean
I'm Sorry by 1970 uh thank you do we
have a second representative Hicks
seconds
um assuming since this pretty much
replaces the entire bill you do not have
much to add on this or do you right
I do not thank you anybody wish to speak
to the ought to pass as amended
seeing none will ask the clerk to call
the rule
okay SB 47 otpa
uh Vice chairman power yes
yes representative Kelly yes
representative Alward yes representative
Brown no
representative Cahill
no
representative stavis yes
representative Tatro
yes
representative tree eleven yes
representative Gilman yes
representative one
yes
you don't like me no I don't
you got me all messed up now because
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
wheeler yeah representative priest yes
and Mr chairman yes
uh ATP passes I have 18 to 2. thank you
Mr clerk any objections to the consent
calendar
I do not see any representative priests
I assume you'll be writing the committee
reports yes I will thank you
okay with that we close the exact
session on Senate Bill 47 and we will go
ahead and open up the exact session on
prohibiting cities towns from adopting
Sanctuary policies
yeah
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman I'd
like to
um offer the
committee
amendment
2023-1983h to Senate Bill 132 and make a
motion ought to pass on the amendment
the motion ought to pass is not
appropriate yet we first have to have a
second on the motion do I have a second
representative L word seconds the motion
would you like to speak to your
Amendment
um yes I would um I apologize for the
miss
Peak there
so um
this this amendment
um
is a revision of the amendment that I
sent out and it's nine of
the amendment that I shared that I
and when I reviewed
um that there were some minor questions
that I had about it but I did want to to
share that Amendment with the committee
so that you had enough time to to look
at it closely
so
um the next day on Tuesday I contacted
OLS to have a discussion when I had
representative L word and I had worked
very diligently on this amendment and
um
I had submitted the changes that I
wanted made and um
unfortunately there was there were some
things that needed to be addressed that
were not included so what I'm going to
do first is I'm going to go through very
systematically and explain and outline
um the changes to the original bill
that this amendment represents
so the first thing is on the cover page
which is not included with this
amendment but you will see it on the
bill
that was received by the Senate the
analysis was updated to reflect the
changes made within the body of the bill
so if on the amendment if you look at
you'll you will see the the amended
analysis
and that would appear on the cover page
of a bill
so the second change in this amendment
is on page one line three
um an act is also amended to read
prohibiting cities and towns from
adopting restrictive policies
on the same page line seven the short
title was also amended to read this act
shall be known as the secure New
Hampshire communities Act
page one line eight the subdivision
title is amended to reflect the new
short title
page one line ten The Heading is
similarly amended
to reflect the new short title
page one line 21.
in the amendment
1960 for some unknown reason there was a
word was flipped
so
um the word in that Amendment
they changed it from detainer to
detainee
so this amendment
1983 changes it back correctly
to
um
detain detainer
then on page two
it would be Roman numeral section 7
um there's significant changes in that
and those changes reflect simplified
language in order to make this bill more
narrow and explicit and representative L
word will speak in Greater detail
um
to that section then on page 2 line 24
in 1960 there was a comma that was
missing so that that was fixed that
Grandma change page two line 25 a
reference to eight USC
1226 was added and then
um on line 36 of page two
the amended language is changed to
reference restrictive policy so from a
high level those are the changes to the
bill that were received in this
committee that are reflected in 19
Amendment 1983.
so um
yeah I'll just hold there and I will let
other people
um comment
thank you represent representative L
word I know you have quite a bit of info
on this so would you please go ahead
please
thank you Mr chairman good morning
everyone
um
I believe that SB 132 was born out of
necessity as some cities and towns and
criminal justice agencies create and
Implement policies and ordinances or
standards
for the management of aliens when
encountered in in the community
or while in custody of law enforcement
the result of an arrest
for a state crime or perhaps for a
different matter related to Public
Safety or national security
after close examination of the bill as
amended by the other body I did some
fact checking and interviewed officials
having first-hand experience with
immigration detainers and I felt the
bill needed Improvement
what this bill does not do
is mandate
apprehensions detentions or arrests the
conducting of raids and checkpoints
arbitrarily conducted investigations or
identification checks
there were claims in
Testament written testimony that
honoring immigration detainers was
mandatory
but
the bill would have to say that it would
have to say shall
enforce immigration detainers such as
Founders in Texas law
so this this bill
is state law that is mirroring federal
law which
is allowed
um
the term anti-sanctuary act had no
contextual meaning based on fact and law
I'm taking to Heart protesters adamant
opposition to the acts title it was
changed to secure New Hampshire
communities act because the bill speaks
to the prevention of policies that would
make communities less safe and secure
um the term Sanctuary policy under Roman
7 underwent a change
um
by eliminating the phrases including but
not limited limited to because that
language was overly Broad
and the phrase cooperating with Federal
immigration laws was vague and subject
to interpretation
for the definition to be fair and
reasonable to those governed by federal
immigration laws and in its application
um the federal law that expressly
addresses restrictions on Communications
um and another type of communication is
addressed in section 1226 which was
one communicates with an official not a
law so the language was changed to item
a communicating with Federal immigration
agency officials pursuant to those
sections
section 1357 of ausc
ifically d
speaks to cooperation with ice relative
to aliens violating controlled substance
laws
and that's a case where if a law
enforcement agent has a reason to
believe that an alien has not been
lawfully admitted
they can inform ice they can request a
determination of whether or not to issue
a detainer or to detain the alien
um and if issued and the alien is not
otherwise detained
I spoke with several
um
uh correctional centers to include
Merrimack and Stratford and I obtained
the policy standard operation operating
procedure from the city of Manchester
and from the state police
and both of them
um Manchester says they will honor
detention uh detainer notices under
certain circumstances and I believe it
mirrors uh federal law
So based on all this research I believe
this bill affords municipalities and
agencies with the ability
to create so-called welcoming policies
and standard operating procedures that
do not provide a safe haven for
non-citizen law Breakers within our
communities
um
than immigrants and non-immigrants are
afforded the benefit of guidelines
regarding the management of any alien
who is subject to federal laws governing
immigration it avoids a hodgepodge of
rules that differ from jurisdiction to
jurisdiction collide with federal law or
hamstring local law enforcement
officials from complying with applicable
federal laws or from exercising their
discretion
there's no inequities in this bill
because it doesn't create a liability
regarding federal state or state
constitutional rights nor does it impose
a mandated financial burden of any kind
since compliance would be in the course
of routine law enforcement duties or
by contract with the federal government
advocacy groups will be able to more
clearly explain to lawfully present
individuals their rights under state law
and
I believe that the collective we we must
be proactive to keep our citizens safe
representative Elward could you turn off
thank you Mr chair
um
a couple of things in this amendment
that I
um still have
um that I don't think that we're fully
addressed that were mentioned inside of
the um hearing was the
um
the definition of local government
entity
included random officials and what they
said and
um I think that a government entity is
the entity itself and no individual
right of no uh
um
no selectmin is representing the
government they only represent when they
vote as a board and so if a Randomness
selectman has some some preferences or
whatever that should not be
considered some government policy so I
have a problem with
um the language on line 18 of of this
amendment on page two
um policy I still think that practice
Customs things Unwritten are still too
vague if you're trying to say that the
government has a policy then make it a
policy that it has to be a written
policy that this is what they're doing
and um then it's clear and you're not
going to court to find out whether or
not
um you know some statistical analysis of
how often they reach out to uh
um the federal government means that
they have uh Unwritten practice of not
doing it I don't think that's
appropriate so I think that we still
need to work on uh Roman six
there
um I think that on line 22 of page two
the restrictive policy means any policy
that prohibits limits or discourages I
think discouraging and limits is kind of
what we're talking about when we're
talking about prohibit
um when we're talking about
prioritization if you say I really would
like you to actually go and Patrol the
streets
instead of writing you know reaching out
to you know spending an hour or whatever
on the phone with the federal government
I think that is a prior
um that may be considered discouraging
that may be to skip
um
considered limiting and so just make it
explicit that it's prohibiting if you
say you cannot do this under any
circumstances this is what you're trying
to not to to limit so I think those
things still need to be worked on and I
think that the
um that there is some interest in
working on that stuff
um and so
um
in in my like overall I kind of agree
with what we did with the the gun stuff
and said like the federal government you
want to make rules you make rules you do
it that's not our problem we don't need
to be funding that or if you fall down
that's not where the state needs to come
and pick up the the slack on that and so
I think in as a matter of State policy
that I think that this is wrong
um but
um I'm happy to to work with and and and
allow that
um some of a possible amendment that
that addresses some of these issues
might be be drafted so I I
um I also think that it would be good to
put something in here that explicitly
states that nothing in this act shall be
constituted to prohibit the
prioritization of of law enforcement
agency resources if this if that's what
um the the advocators of this this uh
language uh believe and that's their
stated
um
um preference and I think it should be
stated inside the bill also
so for those Reasons I'm not going to
vote in favor of this this amendment
um but I do hope that that
um you know if this was to come come on
the floor that they would they'd work to
to address some of those issues that I
still think are um outstanding thank you
thank you
for the comments
representative velocellus
yes thank you Mr chairman
um
the whole concept of immigration policy
is
is at the front of everyone's mindset at
this point because of the crisis that we
have that's occurring all across this
country
media
and all of the information that is
generated sometimes is harmful
to
actually accomplishing the ends that I
think everyone has and that's to to live
in a harmonious
um
civilized society
I think the definitions
as amended
here in this amendment really promote a
better understanding of
uh what our policy here in the state of
New Hampshire in the state of New
Hampshire should be and I will therefore
uh support the event
thank you representative
representative power
I
this is a complicate complex bill
and I spent a lot of time analyzing it
in considering the testimony that we
heard here in this committee
as well as I looked at the um the Senate
hearing and the
testimony there
and I just
um want to emphasize
as I see this bill that with regards to
the issue at hand there there are three
approaches on a spectrum
and those three lanes if you will would
be that we mandate cooperation
and this bill does not do that
and on the other end of the spectrum
would be prohibiting cooperation
through policies that are restrictive
and prohibit
which some municipalities in fact we
know do
and this bill does not
um
it the bill does not
where we want to be is in this this
Middle Lane
where we bring it back to
it's allowing for a cooperation which
makes it therefore discretionary so
we're not we don't want to be at any
extreme
we want to be in the middle and I feel
that this bill language does that to
bring it back to allow that discretion
in the prioritization of of resources in
in what it does do is it it it it
elimits the outright prohibition because
if you think about it prohibiting
policies that prohibit or restrict
cooperation do in fact take away the
discretion
and I think that's an issue and then
what we end up with is a patchwork of
policies
you know across the state and that's not
in the interest
of anybody
it it it
puts into question the Safety and
Security of our citizens and
I don't believe that anybody
um that's really what we want we don't
want that so I just wanted a
to emphasize that in in and direct our
focus on to what the bill is is doing
and it's bringing back that Middle Lane
putting everybody in the Middle Lane
where it
thank you representative for the
comments
representative
go representative clerk go
I always call you clerk I've been called
worse
uh I just want to say a few things uh
this bill's come I built some of this to
come before this committee on the past
couple terms that I've been in and uh
most of you should know that I was in
law enforcement New Hampshire for 30
years and I retired from the uh New
Hampshire State Police and I had several
occasions where I went into this thing
but most important thing I want to
clarify is my entire 30 years I've never
seen a police officer stop someone based
on their nationality of their looks or
anything like that it's always been
based on a violation of New Hampshire
law Noah have I ever seen a police
officer ask anyone for the Visa or the
passport
the occasions I have seen if in
particular actions I've taken I've
stopped someone for a motor vehicle
violation I run his license and it comes
back from ncic that there's a detaining
order from immigration I would help the
dispatcher call Immigration to see if
they want the person to detained if they
did I would take them into custody
bringing before the district court and
he would have his opportunity in court
to say why he shouldn't be detained
um that's the way it's always works as
far as I understand
um I don't know again I know anybody
that's going outside let me see your
Visa I really I really don't see that
but it's my understanding detainers when
the federal government issues those
those are for very serious crimes
federal crimes that those individuals
have committed
um again I just don't want people to
have the conception that a police
officer is about to uh getting paid
overtime or anything else to do any type
of federal law enforcement as far as
immigration is concerned because that's
not the purpose
but if we don't cooperate with the
federal government we're not going to
solve the immigration immigration
problem and again the people that have
the detaining waters the people that
have committed in my experience serious
federal crimes against the citizens of
the United States and I don't think we
should promote those folks running
around to commit federal crimes to State
crimes against our individuals thank you
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and I I would like
to further emphasize and and direct your
attention to um on page two Roman
numeral seven the definition of
restrictive policy
and just emphasize that
this whole section is with respect to
individuals that are detained by or in
the custody
of law enforcement for a specific
purpose and that's for suspected
violation of a state law
so that that's very explicit and and
very narrow in in my reading and
understanding of of the words
um defining restrictive policy so in my
mind that you know cuts out
a whole you know host of scenarios that
people were concerned about and and
spoke
um to during the hearing
um
so again there's no requirement in the
bill to cooperate with an immigration
detainer
it brings it back into that that lane
where it's again
it's at the discretion
of law enforcement
but what the bill does do is it makes it
clear that cooperation cannot be
prohibited
so I I I hope that um
people understand
the scope
of this bill and the intent of the Bill
thank you
thank you representative representative
11.
to address a question to um
representative McDonald AKA our esteemed
clerk
um in regards to the specific
from a from a law enforcement person's
point of view the specific mode of
receiving that information that there is
a quote unquote detainer
out which which I would assume to mean
I've read this paragraph a zillion times
but I still need clarification on what
that means and from whom it comes
if you could enlighten me would you like
to answer that Mr Clark I would be glad
you were now thank you representative
for the questions
the way it worked when I was on the job
issued one maybe one to 10 21 or 10 22
that's a a 21 is a Motor Vehicle Record
and a 22 is a license check which you
can check driver's licenses all over the
country and you can also request
specific things for Pacific States on
Motor Vehicle records
and when you want a 21 or 22 you have a
what's called a 1023 hit that'll come up
and that's an ncic uh hit that's the
national Crim crime information center I
think that's what it's called and that's
uh information that's gathered by law
enforcement agencies entering
information like stolen guns stolen cars
wanted people things like that they
usually all reach to the missing persons
they reach up to the felony level so
when you run that particular name and
date of birth it may be an ncic hit
which would show a detainer you might do
some other again there's a lot of John
Smith's in the world and you now we're
done with the data brush you may do some
further uh asking of the of the person
you have stopped or the I would ask if
it came up as hidden it's the ice cream
detainer I would have the dispatcher
call Immigration advising the
information they have they had the
person stopping the side of the road for
a particular violation and ask them if
they wanted that individual detained for
someone when their Agents come up and
pick them up uh if they said uh no then
I would just go back to them and tell
the person that he stopped that just
will let you know that immigration would
like to speak with you and maybe you
could get together with them you're
missing some documentation or whatever
uh but there is a detainer but at this
particular time uh they don't want to
come up and pick you up uh if they were
detained I would take them to uh I would
have the dispatcher call the court and
say I was detaining someone for an
immigration detainer you'd eventually go
before the judge uh he would plead his
case to the judge you're probably having
a quarter appointed attorney and the
judge would say okay well immigration
has three days to come up and pick him
up or four days or they must come up
tomorrow that's all up to the judge he
decides how long immigration has to come
and pick the pick the individual up I
I do have a bit of a follow-up okay
go ahead thank you very much Mr chair my
follow-up would be how does that
detainer get into the system
it would be again
based on my experience I've been retired
now for several years that retainer that
detainer is put in by and put into ncic
by I believe immigration or whatever the
title is now
thank you thank you Mr McDonald I
representative McDonald I appreciate
your answers thank you ma'am are there
comments
seeing none will ask the clerk to call a
thank you uh Mr chairman this is uh
sb132 Amendment
2023-1983h uh Vice chairman power yes
representative sellers yes click votes
yes representative lasalles yes
representative Keller no
representative Kelly yes representative
Alward yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill
yes
representative Davis no
representative
no
representative tree eleven no
representative Gilman no
representative majority no
representative rung no representative
Gallagher
no representative Hicks no
representative wheeler no
representative priests no
adoption Fields nine to eleven thank you
Miss Clark uh representative power do
you have a motion on the
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to make a
motion ought to pass on Senate Bill 132
FN
thank you do we have a second
representative Elwood thank you
representative
for the discussion on the main Bill
representative wheeler
thank you Mr chairman
um I understand the concern uh that this
bill was brought forth to address
um however I I don't see the effect of
that concern I think it's you know I I
think the internet is a powerful tool
media is a powerful tool and and I think
we're being lied to a little bit this
isn't the southern border this isn't
Arizona or New Mexico or any of the
other states and I understand that
people think it it could be if we don't
pass legislation like this I don't think
that's the case uh we have immigration
laws those laws are being enforced a
place like Peterborough which has one of
these quote-unquote Sanctuary laws I
talked to the chief of police there they
work with immigration they meet with the
immigration officials and they act on
detainments uh so I I just fail to see
where the solution the solution that
this this bill is bringing for so I I we
the representative power brought up uh
this brings us to a middle ground of
discretion it seems to me as though the
discretion is already there and and this
is trying to get a win where there is
none
um
undocumented people uh or illegal
immigrants are are not coming from
spaceships they're not aliens they're
they're undocumented illegal immigrants
and I think that our immigration system
goes much deeper than uh there are
people running around our communities
who need to be picked up and jailed and
thrown back to Nicaragua I think the
problem is that we haven't addressed on
a federal level immigration policy for
the last 40 years and we're seeing the
effect of that right now on the southern
border where and this is where this is
where I might get in trouble with my
Democrat colleagues that there is a
serious Chaos on the southern border I
see that and uh that is as a result of
40 Years of no immigration policy 40
Years of Destruction in in Southern
America and uh you know frankly
um
doing this detaining uh more people
where uh there there are not is that
it's not the way to to solve the
solution and I think that uh
undocumented people uh deserve a better
solution than that
um it's not uh
open Borders or welcoming everyone here
that's
not what anyone is is proposing and I
think we're getting lost in the
conversation there when we when we bring
the national federal immigration
conversation here on to a state level
where it isn't happening it's not
happening and a legislation like this
won't stop it from happening if it was
going to happen so I will be proudly
voting against SB 132.
thank you uh representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair
well I greatly respect and admire my
colleague from the other side
representative wheeler
um the reason why we're state
representatives in New Hampshire is to
look out for our people and I think that
the amendment and this bill
goes a little further to look out for
the rights and protect our people so I
representative priests uh point of
clarification we're just discussing the
an ought to pass motion on sb-132 that
would be correct okay without the
amendment that's correct
representative Edward
thank you Mr chairman
um representative wheeler I'd like to
address uh your use of undocumented
illegal aliens it's that that's not a
statutorily defined uh phrase
uh an alien is anyone who's in the
country who's not a naturalized citizen
so
case in point for this bill
is the example of an ordinance that
appears to limit restrict and prevent
local police from fully communicating or
sharing certain information with
immigration officials is the town of
Harrisville
that enacted an ordinance in 2017 the
Warren article in part reads the police
officers and the performance of their
routine duties
will not ask a person any person about
his or her immigration status and will
refuse to share information regarding
any person with
ice
except in cases involving allegations
against such a person of violent
criminal activity or a violation of New
violent criminal activity is not defined
and it excludes non-violent misdemeanor
crimes that trigger Isis Deport
deportation ability
such as
contributing to the delinquency of a
minor child endangerment
violation of a protective order
failure to register as a sex offender a
possession of child pornography owning a
prostitution business indecent exposure
shoplifting having a fake ID trespass
stalking Etc
so the question is why would any
Community or agency want to refuse
sharing misdemeanor information with ice
and give a free pass to these
um without releasing you know removable
aliens back into the community
potentially exposes law-abiding citizens
and non-citizens to re-offending harm
and the selectman for the town expressed
his opinion that if passed the bill
would render the town ordinance null and
void
well
maybe it should
um it's not the end of the world if this
bill passes the towns can simply amend
their ordinances to comply with SB 132
thank you
foreign
and um contrary to what my esteemed
colleague representative Edward just
said this is not enabling legislation
this is a mandate this is a Statewide
mandate what we're what we're talking
about now is the underlying bill which
prohibits Sanctuary policies and I have
a couple of questions that I would just
like to put out for the good of the
order
and one is
if I sit on a planning board in any New
Hampshire municipality
and we're at a break in the action and
we're talking amongst our colleagues and
the subject of quote unquote Sanctuary
policies comes up which is now what
we're debating here Sanctuary policies
because we're done with the amendment
if we're just casually talking and I say
to a colleague so I saw a story on the
news yesterday about Sanctuary policies
what do you think and my colleague says
well I'm
mixed about it I just don't know what I
think and I say yeah I know some good
things about it some bad things about it
but overall you know I can't see it
where it hurt I could get hauled into
court
under the precepts of this bill
because I am
part of a city
governmental entity as a member of the
planning board now as a member of the
planning board I also enjoy a form of
qualified immunity so how does how do
those two things Square I don't see
where this bill is legal in any sense of
the word because it violates My First
Amendment rights to speak my mind
it potentially violates the Fourth
Amendment right against unlawful search
and seizure and it would immediately
result in lawsuits from any number of
municipalities across New Hampshire
challenging challenging its legality and
therefore resulting in huge expenditures
of funds that would ultimately be borne
representative yokella
thank you
um
I have to agree with representative
wheeler about the the southern border
and the the kind of
um
there is a broken immigration policy in
this country
um and
um
the fact that you have to wait years and
possibly already have a family member
that's in the United States and all of
this stuff for you to be able to come
here
um
is
you know a failure of the federal
government and we are not going to fix
that here and there is also a lot of
concern about that failure
and their failure on the drug policies
um
kind of combining at this Southern
border to you know enhance cartel
activity and all of that stuff that is
having negative effects on the United
States at the southern border and as a
whole like
um some people would like to see
um Fentanyl and stuff like that they
believe that that's a you know
a negative Downstream side effect of
both the drug policy and the immigration
policies that we have in this country
we're not going to fix that in in New
Hampshire and I do
um think that this is kind of a a reach
around kind of way to get at more drug
enforcement
um
and I come I'm completely opposed to the
drug war I think you've we've already
failed and we think it should be I think
it should be stopped and
um
and so I don't like this from that
perspective
I don't think that the that we should be
enforcing Federal
um
uh drug policy in New Hampshire I don't
think that we should be enforcing
Federal Gun policy I don't think we
should be forcing Federal immigration
policy and so I think that under all of
these it's a it's you know the federal
government may be failing they may be
failing on a policy level they may be
failing on a in implementation of their
policy level but that is not really
something that New Hampshire should try
to seek to solve
um
I do
like that we did not change our our
policy in the house that if if a if a
bill comes out with no recommendation
then the person then the the preferred
motion is ought to pass so that if any
of the concerns that we bring here today
can be rectified before that time that
they can offer an amendment
um at that time and hopefully those
concerns can be addressed and so my hope
today is that I would like to see
um some more work being done not that I
will probably ever support such a policy
um but I think I like the conversation
and where it's headed
as far as
um
like on on the Republicans trying to
explain where they where they're coming
from and so while I don't support the
the bill I do hope for that that no
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair
um I need to uh
talk about an incident in Exeter
and we have talked before about uh
enabling laws that are not enabling but
passing laws or bills that reiterate
federal law because it will be easier to
find in New Hampshire law
um
and I think you might agree that the
research through the U.S code is uh can
be very dense
um in Exeter we had an incident where
someone came to the aid of our police
department and then was detained he had
committed no crime
um he was
coordinated with ice and he was detained
and kept for five months at the loss of
his income and uh and
a relationship with his family and the
town was sued and we lost uh forty
thousand dollars so I see that adopting
a sanctuary policy may be necessary in
order to inform our police what they can
uh let's see here who hasn't spoken yet
we'll go to representative Brown I see
your hand up
thank you Mr chairman I have many family
members and many friends in law
enforcement who basically just want to
enforce the law and not be restricted
from enforcing the law so once a
violation has been identified much like
uh representative McDonald indicated
they don't want to be prevented from
doing so and although some people here
might not think that we have issues in
New Hampshire our alarm enforcement
people tell me that that is the case so
I just think that this law would allow
us to address immigration issues when
they're identified not searching them
out but when they're identified like
representative McDonald indicated then
it gives the ability to enforce the law
thank you
representative representative wheeler
thank you Mr chairman just to address
what representative Cahill and
representative Alward said both two
people with whom I have great respect
for and I'm sure you and I will be out
after this and I'm sure representative
Cahill will be talking after this so
this won't change that but I think this
is protecting our people and protecting
the rights of them I have spoken to the
Manchester police I've spoken to my
police chief I've spoken to many people
in my community many people in my
community reached out for this they
don't support this policy and its effect
because they as people who have lived
there that live here their entire lives
want a welcoming and Safe Community for
all people and as representative Gilman
just Illustrated sometimes it's not all
criminals who are being detained by ice
and uh held without their will and
having their lives taken away from them
it's not all criminals it's sometimes
people who are just simply immigrants
who may have their documents Etc and I
think that speaks to representative
point that we need to fix our federal
immigration system so that we're
enforcing the laws that are on the books
and making sure that the ones that are
lacking are strengthened so that
situations like that aren't happening
and that we don't have a border which
people can run over uh with no
uh recourse whatsoever I think that's
something that most people would agree
with um to representative alward's Point
um if you commit some of the crimes you
outlined if you are in possession of
child pornography and cod if you are a a
pedophile and and you are arrested for
that crime uh or if you commit a
felonious murder if you Etc uh you will
go to court and that will be a a
decently large court case and in the
process of you going to court getting
your papers Etc uh immigration will find
you and that is on the books as it
stands and this does not change that at
all if you commit one of those crimes
you're going to jail and in the process
of you going to jail you're going to be
found and immigration will come and take
you and process you uh thus far that's
happens here in New Hampshire that's I
think the the appropriate process and
how it should continue to move forward
and and to representative yokelo's point
I mean we've got the sit alone cartels
basically running the country to our
Southern board I think the problem is
far deeper than some people have crossed
out over in our in our uh in our
communities it's that's not the problem
and I I I just I fail to see that so
thank you Mr chairman I won't speak any
further as a substitute I appreciate
your deference and uh thank you
I think this uh whole issue
that's brought up by
SB 132 is fundamental
to our responsibility as legislators
and the responsibility of government
itself
we are a nation
of laws
we are not a nation of men
now if we took a poll of all the peoples
that inhabit
the planet Earth
I'm sure you would find that a great
percentage of them would like to leave
where they are
and go to a different country
and a great percentage of those would
there are many reasons why people come
here
but one of the overriding reasons above
and beyond the fact that their country
of origin is not a safe country it's
it's not a good place for them to raise
their children
uh another reason is for The Economic
Opportunity so if if we have
uh 300 and some thousand people in this
country
well if we just opened our our I meant
million if we opened our border and let
anybody who wants to come here for
whatever reason
we would be totally inundated with
people
from all over the world we are
our immigration system simply could not
handle it
so where are we today
well for a long time we had
thousands of people coming
across the southern border and yes there
were too many for the people to handle
but they were down there
and
um
and they didn't
seem to come any further
now where are we today we have eight or
ten thousand per day
coming across our border there are tens
of thousands of people that are
trying
to make it to this country in any way
that we can our border patrol and people
at the federal level who are responsible
for enforcing the laws at the border
simply cannot do it they're inundated by
people people are coming in they're
totally unvetted we have no idea of
their health status their legal status
or any other status
so
all of a sudden now
we're we're having people show up in New
York City and Chicago
and Martha's Vineyard and all over the
country by the busload and oh my gosh
full disclosure
several Generations ago my
great-grandfather
was an illegal alien
he was arrested and it was a half a mile
in front of the local sheriff
for shooting one of the king's rabbits
he
stowed away on a ship and came to this
country and that was back before the
Civil War
so I am in a way I have his blood
flowing through my veins
but
I get back to the point if we are going
to be choosing what laws we're going to
enforce and what laws were not going to
enforce and have people in one
municipality
enforcing this and in another
municipality saying you cannot cooperate
with the federal law
and the federal government are the ones
that are supposed to be
in charge here you cannot
cooperate with Federal authorities then
I think you are opening the door
to
now
the impact
of slack immigration policies
affects us not just from an immigrant
standpoint
it affects us
we have a a fentanyl crisis here
I think most people admit that the
fentanyl that is killing tens of
thousands of people here in New
Hampshire
not tens of thousands but we have many
people who are being killed by fentanyl
poisoned it's not drug abuse it's poison
a lot of that fentanyl is coming across
the southern border and a lot of it
comes through ports of Entry why is it
coming through ports of Entry because
so
I think this bill
is a step in the right direction
to get things back in line
to Force the federal government
to take responsible policies to enforce
the law
and that goes right down to the local
level
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman and I I agree with
representative lascalis and I'd like to
acknowledge representative Gilman's
comment
for those of you who are substituting
you may not know that on January 26th of
this year
lobbyists Nate Grays are our good friend
testified before this committee relative
to a child tax credit bill and he stated
as much as it chagrins me to say this
you municipalities need solid guidelines
on what to do
unfortunately we don't have a survey of
all the towns and cities and agencies to
determine the existence of policies that
may be in effect that conflict with
federal law
um
so I I believe this bill provides
guidelines to prevent a hodgepodge of
rules
um
and the towns can create policies as
long as they don't conflict
for the comments
representative sellerson
thank you Mr chair
I think representative wheeler he's half
right
um when it comes to undocumented
because if I go to Canada
and I don't know because Customs I am
there in Canada illegally
but I am undocumented all right so it is
both but it's basically no difference in
this country if I don't have the
paperwork saying I'm here legally I am
illegally here that's number one the
second thing I want to spring up is it
sounds like if we don't have a law
that's a standard through the entire
State you're sowing confusion
and if I was an illegal in this state
I'd be scared to death if I left one
town and went to another and one police
force was talking to another the odd be
picked up in a heartbeat if I wasn't
illegal I wouldn't want to come to this
state without a law at least put in
place so I either know or I don't know
where I stand because when you go to one
town or another you can it could just
thank you representative further
comments
seeing none I have too
uh the first one is actually more of a
procedural or process type of a issue
and it we see this not just in this
building but in many bills
um somebody previously mentioned uh the
the internet and what goes on there
and what I want to talk about is the
amount of inaccurate information that is
put out
um on the internet and two examples of
that is one I know many of you have
received Luts and lots of emails on this
and I can't tell you how many of them
are just rooted in errors and
misinformation I occasionally engage on
some of those and what I have found is
that
um they're usually talking points that
are given to an individual the
individual regurgitates them in an email
and most of the time they're wrong and
when I engage the individual nine times
out of ten that individual has first of
all doesn't respond to a question but
has no idea what they're talking about
and the occasional person who does
respond
they don't know what they're talking
about
that's troubling enough but I'll tell
you what's really troubling is when
somebody testifies in front of this
committee
as a a supposed expert and I'm going to
pick on a police chief who testified
here from one of our major cities
and in his testimonies I'm going to
paraphrase it so if I don't get it
exactly right
that he made the point that he didn't
want his police officers spending time
rounding up
undocumented immigrants and when he was
challenged on that
he went through his paperwork or through
the bill and couldn't find it and then
said well you know I maybe it'll come to
that or something to that effect
it's very disheartening when somebody in
that level of
Authority
makes a statement as inaccurate as as
that so that's my first point on process
the second thing I'm going to talk about
is not necessarily a legal illegal
immigration but unchecked immigration
many of you know I I I fly around the
world on a weekly basis I've been doing
that for almost 38 years now
I have seen
the results in the once pristine cities
of Paris or Zurich or
name just about any European city of the
results of unchecked immigration when I
first started
going to these cities in the mid and
late 80s
Paris for example pristine inside the
parific gorgeous never never any kind of
trash no nothing
but over the years over the 38 years
that I've been going to Paris
it has the social and the fiscal
and I'll talk about Athens if you really
want to talk about fiscal Decay but the
societal and fiscal decays of these
major cities are just really
discouraging you can't go to one of
these cities anymore without seeing in
one of the major squares in Paris inside
the main the main part of the city
statues or fountains are now covered
with graffiti
inside the once beautiful city of Paris
same thing with same thing with
zerk recently I just can't get over how
these cities have deteriorated and the
comment was made earlier well that's not
happening here in New Hampshire I'll
tell you something
in the last three or four years I've
started to see that same
societal fiscal Decay here in New
Hampshire up until a few years ago did
you ever see around the cities of
Manchester many who are from there
graffiti
on the bridge abutments no they were
always pristine did you ever see
graffiti on all the all the wooden
fencing they have to cut down on the
noise no we're seeing that same societal
Decay now I'm not saying that's all on
unchecked immigration but there has been
something that has changed in New
Hampshire over the last few years and I
can tell you unequivocally
I'm seeing the same thing happen in my
great state that I have seen happen into
these great cities throughout the world
so I'd be very cautious
um for saying that it's not happening
here my final point I'm going to state
is the fed's failures at the southern
borders
true you're right that is the fed's
failures
if they fail we need to protect we need
to protect our state
these bills that we're talking about
are
first of all not mandates
but they are for as representative
McDonald's talked about these are for
those committing felonies or serious
crimes this isn't rounding up like the
police chief from Manchester stated so
with that I I will support this Bill
thank you for the comments
representative true 11.
thank you Mr chair while I very much
appreciate your point of view your
knowledge your information as a a world
traveler I must bring us right back to
the state of New Hampshire where we all
live and I must say that after reading
this bill hearing the testimony reading
the amendment listening to people today
this bill is not ready as far as I'm
concerned it's not concise it's not
clear I understand many of the points
made by several speakers this is not
ready to go before the house and I will
not be supporting it thank you
thank you for the comments
seeing none I will ask the clerk to call
scp-132
ought to pass
Vice chairman power yes representative
sellers yes click votes yes
representative lasalles yes
representative Keller
no
representative Kelly yes
representative Alward yes
representative Brown yes
representative Cahill yes Representative
representative Tatro no
representative 11.
no
representative Gilman no
representative majority no
representative run no
representative Gallagher
no representative Hicks no
representative wheeler no
representative Priest No
and Mr chairman yes
uh motion fails uh nine to eleven
Thank You Is there further motions
represented majority
it's a chair I move itl on Senate Bill
132. thank you is there a second
represent priest seconds
um no further comment I think we've said
okay uh representative freeze
yes I appreciate the effort that's been
made by some of the representatives here
to clarify
um once a very ugly Bill and make it
more palatable but I do agree that more
work needs to be done
and that's why I'm opposing this Bill
thank you
thank you for the comments
seeing none watch the clerk to color
roll
SB 132 motion is itl representative
Powers no representative sellers no
clerk votes no representative Los Alice
no
representative Kelly no
representative Allwood no
representative Brown no
representative Cahill no
representative stavis yes
representative yes representative tree
eleven yes representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative rung yes representative
Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative wheeler
representative priest yes Mr chairman
no
10 to 10 Mr chairman
uh tend to turn that motion fails do we
have a further
motion
actually I'm gonna have to ask the clerk
not this clerk the other clerk where we
uh representative do you have a motion
um let's take a
five minute ten minute recess please be
back at 10 30 11 30.
foreign
hey everybody we're going to be back on
this now everybody take their seats
please
foreign
that can't be good okay uh we're back
and uh having seen no more motions uh we
will uh this will go to the floor
without recommendation so what I'm
looking for is uh somebody from
one side and the other to write the
committee reports I'm assuming on our
side it'll be representative power
representative Elwood will write it for
our side and representative stavis
all right for the dissenting side
um
all right so that I believe believe
so does anybody have anything else yeah
representative status
Mike what is the required um submission
no can do I'm kidding
um what is today Wednesday uh by uh
Wednesday four o'clock uh Friday four
o'clock would be great
okay well thank you everybody uh thank
you for those who sat in representative
wrong representative wheeler and
representative sellers thank you and
that's all for today thanks uh
representative lasalles
with respect to to any scheduling have
we completed our business as far as the
committee as of now we have unless for
some weird things something else comes
over but yeah as of now that should
complete us
yeah well representative Powers talking
about the retain bills but those will be
in the fall so
as far as I'm concerned we are done
through
when this uh we finish up here in June
as far as this committee meeting we're
s